Zach Galifianakis and Will Ferrell
playing politicians I will give these
idiots this they have the most accurate
portrayal of politicians I've ever seen
[Music]
the campaign so the campaign stars Will
Ferrell and Zach Galifianakis little
Ferrell gets elected every term because
no one goes against him but John Lithgow
and Dan Aykroyd are a couple of rich
dudes who are like ah we need someone
new that we can control I get
Galifianakis he's an idiot will control
him
now Galifianakis is in the race to win
do you think it's Zach Galifianakis and
Will Ferrell playing on the absurdity of
politics this is gold
I had a few funny moments it did I
laughed at a few scenes but in the end I
was like those movies kind of chopping
it falls flat not as funny as it should
have been I mean Will Ferrell and Zach
Galifianakis potheads have professed for
years that these guys are like comedic
gods and the guys are talented these are
like a couple of those comedic actors
that just commit to roll
so like Robert Downey jr. character and
Tropic Thunder they don't break
character until the DVD commentary or
blu-ray I mean I liked the point of the
movie and that is that there are
problems in politics and someone who
wants to get elected to help the people
that they serve should be elected right
the problem is rich asked people back
idiots and so now we just have it iasts
to vote for the movie plays on that and
it exposes that and shows that I like
that about this movie and the fact that
when politicians run for any office it's
not about okay here's what I want to do
to make it better it's all about that's
why that guy's sucks is because he
colored outside the lines in grade
school you can't elect him he's an idiot
I like the fact that it addressed that -
these are good points at the movie makes
a paean said as an entertaining movie it
fell flat it's ultimately about two
characters that can out dumb each other
for the audience there are gonna be
people who dig this movie because I like
Will Ferrell and Zach Galifianakis
absolutely yes for me it takes more than
just a couple names and I'm not sure if
I should hold a movie to the standard of
comedy that I've seen throughout the
year but you really can't help it when
you see a comedy can't help but be like
us not as funny as this movie I've seen
this year or this movie I've seen this
year namely Ted the dictator and 21 Jump
Street all were funnier than this movie
and generally speaking I have seen
funnier political movies than the
campaign the one that stole the entire
movie for me was Dylan McDermott he
played Zach Galifianakis as campaign
manager he was the best
he was funny as hell he was shady you're
like I don't know if I should dresses
dude he's kind of
easy but he was really slick and smooth
an awesome best character by far
he stole the entire movie he made the
movie funny the baby getting punched was
great though I like that you saw from
the trailer Will Ferrell just punches a
baby but in this movie you see it when
the fist hits the baby you see the baby
is like face move in slow motion oh it's
all rippling you're like they did that
in a movie whatever a movie can push the
boundaries of comedy like that I'm
always like yeah you get points so since
comedy is so subjective I don't know if
you're gonna dig this movie I feel funny
parts but I can guarantee you this
movie's not going to be as funny as you
want it to be in the end I will say the
campaign would be a good time if you're
drunk yeah now what's your party
political movie had to be done so your
favorite political comedy if you don't
have a comedy hack any movie what is it
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]